e
ce qu'ils y voient dans la cour
d'école. Portrait d'une série
qui inquiète et qui fascine
avec Nabi-Alexandre Chartier.
- Vous tous ici présents
vivez sur le fil du rasoir.
- "Le jeu du calmar",
"Squid Game", c'est la série
dont tout le monde parle
en ce moment. Un mois après
son arrivée sur Netflix,
elle a été vue dans 111 millions
de foyers à travers le monde,
caracolant en tête dans plus
de 80 pays, marquant ainsi
le plus gros démarrage pour
une série sur la plateforme.
Dans le "Jeu du calmar",
des gens pauvres et endettés,
s'affrontent dans des épreuves
inspirés de jeux de cours
d'école. Le vainqueur remportera
près de 50 millions $.
Mais attention, c'est un piège
meurtrier puisque les perdants
du jeu seront trucidés.
NICOLAS ARCHAMBAULT,
Festival de film Fantasia
- D'après moi, on dénonce la
violence, ça c'est un autre
élément qui est typique
du cinéma coréen, c'est d'amener
une critique sociale et souvent,
ça touche à la lutte des classe
puis cette violence-là
est l'image de la violence
dans la société.
- La Corée du sud mise sur ses
exportations culturelles, comme
"Soft power". Après les succès
des groupes de Kpop, après
le triomphe du film "Parasite"
à Cannes et aux Oscars,
"Squid Game" est un nouveau coup
de maitre pour le Pays du matin
du matin calme.
- Même quand il y a des éléments
fantaisistes, il y a toujours,
toujours un certain réalisme
au niveau des interaction
entre les personnages,
au niveau... on voit la violence
on voit les impacts
de la violence.
- Et la série "Squid Game"
est violente, très violente
même, et bien qu'elle soit
déconseillé au moins de 17 ans,
en Europe aux États-Unis
et même ici, des voix s'élèvent
pour mettre en garde
les parents.
FRANÇOIS NORMANDEAU, enseignant
de 6e année, École Plein soleil
- Les enfants jouaient
à 123 soleil, mais lorsque
les enfants étaient éliminés,
au lieu de tout simplement
sortir du jeu, ils faisaient
des gestes comme s'ils avaient
des fusils, donc ils se tiraient
et les élèves faisaient semblant
de mourir, donc directement
calqué sur  l'émission.
- Une situation qui inquiète
aussi la psychiatre
Marie-Ève Cotton.
MARIE-ÈVE COTTON, médecin
Psychiatre et professeure
- Je serais craintive pour des
enfants de 12 ans et moins que
ça puisse susciter des réactions
de peur. Cette anxiété-là
peut ensuite induire soit
des cauchemars, des troubles
de sommeil, etc.
- Et même pour des jeunes ado,
elle recommande la vigilence
même si le contrôle
parental a ses limites.
- C'est pour ça qu'à
ce moment-là, ma stratégie
serait peut-être... Si je sais
que de toute façon, il va y être
exposé, de le voir avec lui
ou de lui en parler
si je m'apperçois qu'il l'a vu
pour qu'il puisse exprimer
soit ses craintes, soit
ses réactions.
- C'est pas juste, ce qui est
arrivé!
- "Squid Game" est un phénomène
mondial pour public averti
et non un jeu d'enfant.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canda, Montréal.